now to the reason that we are here
Sunday's Academy Awards the star is
already in party mode but for nominee
Tom Cruise well it is all about Landing
the plane on Top Gun Maverick's historic
run
Tom was all smiles snapping selfies at a
special screening of Maverick on board a
U.S Navy aircraft carrier in the
Adriatic Sea last week also there Ted
lassos Hannah waddingham who breaking
casting news joined the cast of Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 2. Tom
will take a break from shooting to fly
into La as his 1.5 billion dollar
Blockbuster could take home best picture
this is quite a moment this Tom Cruise
lookalike joined Kelly and Ryan for this
spoof in honor of their post Oscar show
huh wait what gun School
is that why we're wearing these costumes
and Hal's best supporting actress
nominee Angela Bassett prepping by
working there she is on set of Fox's
9-1-1 yesterday in LA but in the heart
of Hollywood Oscar preps are rolling
along
people have been asking is there going
to be any trouble this year oh I think
the decision to go was a champagne
carpet rather than a red carpet shows
how confident we are that no flood will
be shed
my wife's name
certainly something that we can can and
will address in a comedic fashion we're
going to acknowledge it and then we're
going to move on
Jimmy's the host his wife Molly McNerney
is one of the show's executive producers
who helped make sure the Oscars will
have a crisis team in place when it all
goes down live Sunday on ABC we're
definitely overthinking every joke right
now I I think every major event I've
worked on in the last 20 years has some
kind of security and some kind of Crisis
management because that's part of what
live events are all about and in terms
of being married to the host I think we
fought over a joke while brushing our
teeth last night so yeah the jokes are
stacked and so is this year's lineup of
performers no Lady Gaga she's busy
shooting the Joker sequel but we got
Rihanna Fresh Off The Super Bowl
performing her nominated track from
wakanda forever
best supporting actress nominee
Stephanie Shu and David Byrne will join
the band Sun Lux for this is a life from
everything everywhere all at once Lenny
Kravitz was tapped for the in memoriam
segment and Sophia Carson is teaming up
with 14-time nominee Diane Warren for
their nominated song Applause and this
could be the the year Diane finally
takes home the trophy 14 Oscar
nominations and it's still exciting
getting chosen to be one of five songs
of hundreds of songs every year when
there's only one song category in the
Academy Awards is a big deal
also a big deal the lineup of presenters
including Dwayne Johnson Halle Berry
John Travolta Emily Blunt Michael B
Jordan and Melissa McCarthy what I do
means something Brad Pitt wasn't
nominated but he could be a surprise
presenter we do know his four hundred
dollars a bottle Rose will be on hand
Fleur de merival is the official Oscars
bubbly how many cases of Booth are
shipped to the Dolby so it will be 2 000
bottles but how many are left
none zero and the party continues at the
Oscars official post show bash the
Governor's Ball where Chef Wolfgang Puck
and his crew are gearing up to serve
around 4 000 people think everybody
gonna ask for the beef wellington for
sure and the chicken pot pie because
those are almost comfort food and when
you don't eat all day you want something
warm and something if it feels good in
your tummy
thank you